bueno mean hombres voila my name is
Guadalupe avena I'm 53 years old almost
54 I live on the fingers on a door in
the community of the longer my project
in the south of Costa Rica joy cantado
more on a singer I've been doing it for
many years and I compose because I
studied music better than being but I
also paid and I've written a few books
and I run workshops in several
communities on management in the arts
sector I work with people este trabajo
college ending
la flama Lisa so me parece I think
globalization is fascinating it brings
many things closer to us that we'd never
ever dreamt of before I could never have
imagined being able to watch nomads
walking through the desert on television
ando en el Sahara por ejemplo polo no
Madonna and I couldn't have imagined
seeing the soy plantations in the Amazon
that are destroying the rainforest
ultimo de SOI on llama Sonia por ejemplo
destroy yandel voce
me preocupa mucho what worries me is
that I haven't learned how not to worry
that's the biggest learning process I'm
going through now yes learning to live
in the moment yo en el que me encuentre
on este momento aprender a venir al dia
Mira the wonderful sound of the insects
hear the cicadas it's impressive isn't
it
yo creo que in Costa Rica were mad about
turrialba cheese on a warm tortilla
queso to Real ma y una tortilla Caliente
basically I work but sometimes I lie
down and read or watch a film o alguna
believe Allah